zum reinkommen gleich mal eine wichtige
frage wie geht's eigentlich unserer
gruppe das kommt ganz darauf an wen man
da fragt die einen sagen der laden ist
ganz kurz vorm auseinanderfliegen andere
finden es läuft eigentlich super also
vor allem das kabinett selber findet
dass unsere regierung haben sie
vielleicht gelesen hat diese woche ihre
große halbzeit bilanz veröffentlicht und
ist ziemlich zufrieden mit sich warum
auch nicht warum auch nicht oder wie
meine mutter früher mal gesagt hat wenn
ich ein bild gemalt habe uli wichtig ist
doch dass ist dir gefällt es
zwischenzeugnisse schüler die sich ihr
zeugnis selbst ausstellen die groko
stellt sich also ein gutes zeugnis aus
mit großartigen noten würde ich auch
machen wenn ich mein zeugnis schreiben
müsste herr die schüler wollen ja
versetzt werden ich fand es jedenfalls
toll weiß ich wie es ihnen ging aber
grottenschlecht
in croydon schlechten ist natürlich
unsinn was stimmt vor allem die cdu
wirkt orientierungslos mit ihrem
spitzenduo einer vorsitzenden hkk die
offensichtlich nicht führen kann und
einer kanzlerin die nicht mehr führen
will
das ist ja die realität entschuldigung
ja ist aus dem neuen heft us tricks und
die geschönte halbzeitbilanz sehr
langweilige band die new york times
nennt unsere regierung in berlin
zombie koalition zitat unfähig zu
handeln aber nicht bereit zu sterben
es ist ein bisschen hart aber in der
sache außenpolitisch ist deutschland
tatsächlich ein totalausfall
obwohl anna gerät also a kk ja
neuerdings mehr bundeswehreinsätze
fordert und sich überhaupt sehr
international gibt präsident obama hat
oft zu seinen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern gesagt und mehr poppiger
kann ich das noch einmal haben worauf
obamas mitarbeiter gesagt haben hey
don't tell me that problem war dass nur
halt auf tschechisch bitte frage warum
gibt es für kaka eigentlich keine
rückendeckung von merkel die chefin
guckt sich das scheitern ihrer
kronprinzessin in aller ruhe an gibt es
noch nicht achten sie mal darauf merkel
ist sowieso nur noch lustlos und total
mürrisch da wird wie diese woche sogar
sachsens ministerpräsident zum büttel
gemacht willst du anfangen wenn ich hier
ganz weg bringen kannst du dir sonst
wohin
fakt ist die groko hat natürlich einiges
abgearbeitet stichwort pflege kita sowas
dass das soll man nicht schlecht reden
und wenn man es trotzdem versucht gibt
es ordentlich ärger mit unserer
familienministerin
dann wird die giftig die gefallen es
sind 1200 maßnahmen im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart davon 300 gesetzesvorhaben
sie können doch genau sich das anschauen
was erledigt weil es ist nicht erledigt
das wie mitschwimmen können kann das
kind schwimmen kannst nicht schwimmen
kann man zählen so gut ist ja gut
matter bei frau dr gefeiert
krieg direkt angst ja die groko hat auch
was geschafft hat sie recht aber jetzt
aktuell wirkt sie eben nur noch gelähmt
gerade bei zukunftsfragen und das sind
blödes timing ganz blöde styling
angesichts der erschreckenden afd
erfolge im osten hier so wurde frau
merkel am montag in zwickau empfang
lässt man das volk nichts an seinem
vermeintlichen vertreten
zeit
es war das denn
ja ich weiß nicht wie es eben geht aber
da ist mir persönlich das volk deutlich
unheimlicher als die gewählten vertreter
aber wie geht es jetzt weiter mit der
groko das ist ja die entscheidende frage
ich behaupte die quälen sich tatsächlich
nur noch und das beste beispiel ist der
streit um die grundrente dieser
würdelose streit schon wieder vertrag
die grundrente steht im
koalitionsvertrag allerdings
ausdrücklich mit bedürftigkeitsprüfung
hat die spd so unterschrieben
wahrscheinlich hatte olaf scholz seine
lesebrille vergessen keine ahnung
grundrente ist eine lebensleistung kein
almosen dafür hat man mindestens 35
jahre eingezahlt wenn auch meist als
niedriglöhner um den die paar kröten
mehr nicht zu können muss man schon
charakterlich deformiert sein also in
der jungen union
wenn wir eine grundrente jetzt machen
dann nur mit einer echten
bedürftigkeitsprüfung ich persönlich
sage es ganz ehrlich aus meiner sicht
sollte es eigentlich gar keine
grundrente geben ja ganz ehrlich aus
meiner sicht sollte eigentlich auch
keine junge union geben aber hat ja
keiner gefragt ja aber auch eine meldung
aus dieser woche wer sich ein
elektroauto kauft das mehr als 40.000
euro kostet der krieg bald 5000 euro
dazu geschenkt übrigens ganz ohne
bedürftigkeitsprüfung ja wir brauchen in
deutschland endlich frische
unverbrauchte ideen gegen altersarmut
sie haben angst vor altersarmut aber
sind zu alt für den enkeltrick dann
versuchen sie es mal mit dem opa trick
rufen sie philipp am tor an und bitten
sie ihn um geld
hallo ist da wirklich mal als du klein
warst habe ich dir hunderttausend euro
geliehen
die brauche ich jetzt wieder trick
nummer zwei starben
zack wird die lebensversicherung
ausbezahlt oder stadt grundrente mütter
rente
denn die gibt es ohne
bedürftigkeitsprüfung einfach noch mal
mutter werden kann doch nicht so schwer
sein
ihre deutsche rentenversicherung
[Musik]
für viele ansätze gefragt
immerhin heißt es liegt jetzt ein
kompromiss in der luft um sogenannte
mitnahmeeffekte bei der grundrechte zu
vermeiden könnte man das einkommen
prüfen nur das einkommen es wäre ganz
einfach teile der union sind trotzdem
dagegen genau wie die sogenannte
initiative neue soziale marktwirtschaft
hier die schalten gerade ganzseitige
anzeigen kostet richtig geld steht dann
gießkanne stadt zukunft ganz fetten die
grundrente die uns allen die zukunft
klaut der von arbeitgeberverbänden
getragene lobbyverband argumentiert nur
einkommensprüfung reicht nicht wir
brauchen trennte
da muss auch eine vermögensprüfung her
genau zu dem thema veranstalten die zur
stunde eine pressekonferenz in einem
kölner hotel um die ecke ich würde sagen
hören einfach mal rein
ja ich höre gerade das zdf ist jetzt
auch live drauf
herzlich willkommen zu unserer pk zum
thema grundrente ein verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit
unser aller geld meine damen und herren
wird verschenkt an menschen die sich aus
welchen gründen auch immer entschieden
haben ihr leben lang in niedriglohn zu
arbeiten und das stand heute ohne jede
vermögensprüfung diesen gießkannen
wahnsinn wollen wir stoppen
das zum beispiel ist frau peukert sie
arbeitet hier als reinigungskraft und
bekommt pro zimmer sieben euro 30
außerdem besitzt sie fünf mietshäuser in
frankfurt zwei ferienwohnungen auf sylt
und eine apothekenkette im badischen und
wenn ich nach der spd geht kriegt sie
jetzt noch grundrente obendrauf
das ist herr jaroslaw der es
fensterputzer auf 400 euro basis er erbt
in wenigen jahren die firma miele ja
traurig wenn ich dann kurz ein haken
darf gießkanne es misst deswegen ja auch
einkommensprüfung aber sie können doch
nicht leugnen dass wir auf ein riesiges
altersarmut problem zu steuern
ja herr werke gehen sie doch einfach mal
auf unsere seite da erklärt ihnen
ein echter professor alles was sie zum
thema altersarmut wissen müssen
das ist relativ einfach zu beantworten
es gibt keine altersarmut in deutschland
sie ist quasi irrelevant so gibt es
sonst noch fragen ja ich hätte eine was
ist denn mit den 430.000 renten dann die
sich aktuell bei der tafel ihr essen
holen haben sie nicht zugehört die sind
quasi irrelevant hätten wir das auch
geklärt wer von der initiative fordern
eine echte bedürftigkeitsprüfung hier so
wäre das in einer idealen welt da sitzt
dann so eine möchtegern grund rentnerin
am tisch und dann kommt die
bedürftigkeitsprüfung reicht guckt ob
die wirklich bedürftig ist kann ja sein
dass die noch irgendwo aktien oder
goldmünzen versteckt findet man immer
noch vermögenswerte hierzu leisten
bingo eine ganze tüte voller
pfandflaschen nix grundrente und wieder
hat die gerechtigkeit gesiegt wie schön
valerie niehaus mal mutter mein arzt hat
mir verboten mich weiterhin so
aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag menschen überall
lassen ihre texte grafiken liegen
und hier last jetzt dass felix ein
beschissenes ab
[Musik]